you should have taken the round for
yourself Jamie told me about the day
King's Landing fell he was sitting in
the Iron Throne and you made him give it
up all you needed to do was climb the
steps yourself such a sad mistake I've
made many mistakes in my life but that
wasn't one of them oh but it was when
you play the game of Thrones you win
will you die
there is no middle ground
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I actually
want to talk about the characters that I
believe will survive the entire series
but before I get into that I just want
to let everyone know that the next
winner from my Game of Thrones series
giveaway has been randomly selected and
your name will be announced at the end
of this video I still have a few seasons
left of the Game of Thrones series that
I am given away so if you want a chance
to win one of them just go to the link
down in the description but let's begin
I'm sure most of you have seen my season
a death prediction videos by now in
those videos I was pretty confident
those characters would die but there are
also some characters who I am pretty
confident will survive the entire series
as well and then there are actually a
few characters I haven't decided on yet
but today I just want to talk about the
characters that I can see making it out
of this alive and I will be honest there
aren't many that I would guarantee will
live because I do think the majority of
the cast will die by the end I actually
did a live stream on Friday night for
everybody on patreon which I will be
doing every Friday night from now on but
during that stream someone asked me
which characters I thought would live
and I apologize because I can't remember
exactly who asked me this question I
think it's no secret that everybody in
Westeros is potentially on the verge of
being killed now that the night king is
south of the wall and he's riding on a
blue flame breathing dragon with a
hundred thousand White's marching under
him plus several giants and having the
ability to raise the dead pretty much
all of the characters are in danger
right now and this is just going to be
one of the wars they're gonna have to
face because Cersei still has no
intentions of making any alliances other
than hiring the golden company to go to
war for her so I expect to see a lot of
bloodshed in this final season not to
mention HBO did bring back Miguel
supports Nick to direct several episodes
and if you don't know who Miguel
supports Nick is he is the director who
did episodes like hardhome and battle of
the bastards which is perfect because he
can potentially direct another big
battle against the dead and a big battle
against Cersei
I am extremely confident they brought
Miguel back to the
like some next-level war scenes and if
you want to know which characters I
think will die during these wars then go
back and check out my season 8 death
videos but I did enough setup now let's
discuss who I think will live when it's
all said and done and the dust settles
who will be there to ensure the way of
living can be better than it was before
who will be there for the dream of
spring phase I'm gonna go with a very
obvious choice for most people with my
first pick
I think Samwell Tarly will survive the
Game of Thrones I would be absolutely
stunned if Samwell Tarly died next
season which is why I have to put him on
my character survival list if Sam died I
would be even more surprised than I was
when I saw Ned Stark get beheaded let's
just put it that way
Sam is kind of one of the perfect
candidates to survive all of the
fighting and be left around to help
restore the Seven Kingdoms now I know
some people think Sam will actually be
fighting in the great war because he
still has hearts bein with him but I
honestly don't see him doing much
fighting unless he absolutely has to
like maybe protecting Gilly and baby Sam
if something were to happen in a white
Walker or white would get close enough
to them but other than that I really
don't think Sam is gonna be out on that
battlefield I just don't see that
happening but I could be wrong Sam is
one of the most intelligent characters
remaining in the show and I think he's
gonna find a way to survive and he will
be one of the few characters that help
establish new laws and ways of living so
that future generations can prosper and
live a more civilized lifestyle than
those who came before them when this
series ends I don't think there will be
one king or queen ruling over the Seven
Kingdoms I don't see the survivors
wanting to allow one person to have that
much power again unless it was someone
like John a person who is an evil and
corrupt it would need to be a person who
is willing to do the right thing for all
of the people instead of just looking
out for their own desires I think the
new system that gets put in place will
be part of the bittersweet ending I
think the bitter part will be losing
most of the beloved characters and
several of the kingdoms being destroyed
but the sweet part will be clearing out
most of the corrupt and evil people that
way the new generation doesn't have to
put up with the same [ __ ] that everyone
else had to deal with I guess you could
say breaking the wheel so to speak I
think brain of
earth will survive the entire series
also everyone already knows she is one
of the best fighters in Westeros and she
has a Valyrian steel sword Brienne
should have no problem surviving any war
she already has the right training in
the perfect weapon to defend herself
against anyone except for the dragons
and Giants of course but you know what I
mean
what I think will happen is Brienne will
survive but Jaime and tour men will
actually die the two men that are
closest to Brienne will lose their lives
unfortunately and it will continue that
cycle of Brienne losing the man that she
loved and in this case she will even
lose a man that loves her
I could see Jaime or torment sacrificing
themselves to save Brienne if push comes
to shove but just to be clear I don't
want either one of them to die I would
actually love to see tormund become a
made man in a new house Giantsbane be
established
but I just don't know if his story's
gonna end happily but I do believe Bryan
will be another one of those characters
that survives and helps restore the
lands she is all about honor and doing
the right thing she has also had her own
moments of walking that grey line but
overall Brienne is a really good person
and I would be pretty confident she
could help make Westeros great again
Gendry is another character that I
believe will survive the series as well
he falls right in line with that younger
generation of characters who needs to be
around for the rebuilding and dream of
spring phase someone needs to be there
to carry on the Baratheon name and I'm
still confident that John Ian or
Daenerys will legitimize ginjury and
make him a Baratheon and I am still
strongly holding out hope that the
Starks and Baratheon's can join their
houses just like Robert told Ned back in
season one Gendry will be in Winterfell
when season 8 begins and we have songs
of stark and Arya Stark there as well
Gendry needs to marry one of the stark
daughters preferably Arya because they
already have a great relationship
together now I know Gendry is older than
Aria but Arya has definitely grown up
since the last time that they saw each
other
personally I would be perfectly fine
with those two hooking up but if not
then maybe him and Songza can hit it off
and have a child together in there Stark
and Baratheon baby could grow up with
Daenerys and John's baby I can see
missandei surviving the series also
she's not gonna be out there fighting
anyone and she hasn't really made any
enemies that would put a price on her
head
so I don't see any reason why she would
die unless she was put in a very
vulnerable position like I said I'm one
of my death prediction videos I think
grey worm will die but missandei will
live they spent enough time getting
people invested into the gray warmer
mass and a love story so now I think
it's time they ripped some people's
hearts out by killing grey worm during
the Great War I don't want that to
happen but he will probably die he has
never fought an enemy like this before
and he has never fought in the north
before either as great as grey worm
might be I don't think he has what it
takes to survive against the night king
in his army I also believe Tyrion
Lannister will survive all of the
bloodshed as well I talked about this a
little bit with some of you during the
livestream so I don't want to go on
another rant about how I felt about
Tyrians character these last few seasons
but let's just say I think he can do
better and I'm hoping there is a silver
lining at the end of this series for him
Tyrion is another character who I am not
entirely sure we will see him fighting
on the battlefield during season eight I
know he was willing to fight on multiple
occasions throughout this series but I
just don't see him getting suited and
booted again unless he absolutely has to
of course which is possible because they
might need every swingin dick in the
field against the night king but I think
Tyrion will remain as a councilman for
now and I believe he will carry this
type of role into the future Tyrion has
made some very poor decisions over the
years but deep down he does have a good
heart in the television series and I
think he would be a good candidate to
help rebuild and restore things to some
sort of normalcy after the dust settles
I truly believe if they can defeat the
night king and Cersei and Euron and
people like that then they will have a
good chance at turning Westeros into a
more civilized place to live now many
people will die during this process as
they try to rid the world of evil but if
this can be achieved they will have
something to look forward to the
sacrifices would be worth it in the end
if the next generation can have a more
peaceful place to live I might actually
end up making another video about which
characters I think will live because
like I said at the beginning of this
video there are still a handful of
characters that I haven't decided
whether I think they will live or die
yet I will have to think about that some
more before I am confident and saying
one thing or the other but the
characters that I have listed today I am
confident they will win the game of
Thrones they have all taken losses along
the way but in the end they will win
just by simply surviving this dangerous
and deadly game but now it's time to
announce the next winner of my Game of
Thrones series giveaway then I will end
the video that way I don't keep rambling
and taking up too much of your time
today's winner is Priscilla seaman from
Tampa Bay Florida
congratulations Priscilla just make sure
you send me a private message on youtube
or you can email me and let me know what
season a game of Thrones you want I
still have two seasons left that I am
giving away so good luck to everyone
else that has or will enter just use the
link that's down in the description
thank you all for watching I really do
appreciate that and thank you to all my
patreon supporters have a great day
everyone I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
you